a lot of big brands are getting
increasingly creative about how they
allow customers to use technology to
order their products ok this is true
someone here came across this new Pizza
Hut promotion offering pie tops that let
you order a pizza directly from your
sneakers the sneakers are called pie top
a light eye top yes
they're called pie tops and you push
that button and it will order a pizza
for you Wow
yes it's craziness then I saw this ad
from another company using a similar
concept and man they took this basic
idea of using technology to order
something from them they took this much
much further check out this ad
oh I want more del Taco but my body is
maxed out no mass no hi Kevin Spacey
here
why not satisfy your hunger the instant
your body's ready for with the del taco
del flesh Oh every flush tells Del Taco
your body just made room for uno moms
you mean all I have to do is and the
more you use it the more del tacos del
flusher perfects its intuition
anticipating your body needs and
gradually reducing the lag time
consumption
and elimination until your body and no
achieve a perfect synchronized loop
which we call del Finity
what is Delft benedi it's a gateway to a
higher plane of perception a place where
past present and future blends
seamlessly
I'm the thievery and the meaning of
human existence is revealed within a
multiverse where all reality and reason
melts away giving you an unencumbered
vision of the Infinity I'll swallow a
soul plus our new crunch tada tostada
and dry our body activated soft drink
dispenser the Del Taco del wizzo del
Taco oh my god what have we done pretty
good right well we're out of the
business thank you
[Laughter]
you